i promise i'll do better mr hornberg
sure you will i just
i just love television so much we all do
oh i don't believe in hypothetical
situations mr donaghy
that's like lying to your brain i don't
drink coffee sir
i don't drink hot liquids of any kind
that's the devil's temperature
reverend gary did the math and guess
what the world is ending tomorrow
and you're happy about that oh of course
i get to go to heaven
and receive my reward 72
virgin margaritas hold the salt if
you're not reading the bible in german
you're not getting the real frustration
of it
okay a parcel man has never been called
mr outside of an execution chamber
there are only two things i love in this
world everybody
and television what's your dream job
where do you see yourself in 10 years
well you know how much i love television
sir so i guess my dream would be to one
day
run the network just kidding
there won't be a network but whatever
people are watching
i want to be in charge of it do you know
why i put up with this pitiful job mr
donaghy
why fetch these folks lunches and clean
up their barfs
because they make television and more
than jazz or
musical theater or morbid obesity
television is the true
american art form think of all the
shared experiences television has
provided
for us from the moon landing
to the golden girls finale from walter
cronkite denouncing vietnam
to oprah pulling that trash bag of fat
out in a wagon
from the glory and the pageantry of the
summer olympics
to the less fun winter olympics so
please
don't tell me i don't have a dream sir i
am
living my dream
[Music]
oh my how'd he get that up there
there's no business like show business
like
no business i know
everything about it is appealing
everything that traffic will allow
no where can you get that special
feeling then when you're stealing
that extra bow miss lemons yeah
this is pete's wedding ring i won it
last night but i don't think i should
keep it could you give it back to him
for me
yeah okay did you win this too
i did i love how the light catches it
like diamonds
kenneth it is diamonds
ah hi mr donaghy can i help you with
something
you are a puzzle kenneth ellen
and i'm going to solve you
[Music]
yes i am sometimes life is complicated
there isn't always a right
answer say you're in a lifeboat
you're on a lifeboat uh kenneth
a word balloon
good morning mr donaghy go to hell no
thank you
time to die we're both hard workers when
i was your age i was putting myself
through college in boston
paddling swan boats for the tourists is
that a euphemism for some kind of sex
worker
search oops i just took my picture with
that little camera thing
all right i just need to erase that
picture whoops i just made it the
desktop image how did i do that
emailing image to address book what is
wrong with me oh
i just took a picture of both of us how
do you do it kenneth how do you sit here
every day taking crap from people and
you keep smiling
my mother always told me that even when
things seem bad
there's someone else who's having a
worse day like being stung by a bee
or getting a splinter or being chained
to a wall in someone's sex dungeon
kenneth i wonder what it's like seeing
the world through your eyes
i don't know mr donaghy i think i see
the world pretty much the same as
everyone else
really because i think you're very
special kenneth
pardon me to be able to get so much joy
from simple faces
why did you bet that terrible hand why
because i believe that life is for the
living
i believe in taking risks and biting off
more than you can chew
and also people are yelling and i got
confused about the rules
[Music]
who is it it's kenneth from the nbc page
program
i'm here for a pick up from kieran
hello gentlemen ah thank goodness air
conditioning
oh what does that tattoo mean when i get
nervous i ask a lot of questions
do y'all have a bathroom i could use
y'all have long fingernails
now do y'all rent this space or do you
own it hey
that's a funny-looking fish what is that
like a grapefruit knife
do you have a cell phone what's your
plan hey they didn't bring any sodas
i'll call kenneth
seriously where is kenneth
happy anniversary mrs jordan
excuse me do y'all just have noodles
with butter
you know what we've never done grizz
fight each other
sorry sorry that happens sometimes when
i unhinge my pelvis
ken you don't want to be a page forever
who said i've been alive forever
what kenneth's the best he knows what i
want before i do
who's hungry i wanted waffles
[Music]
go get help girl
he'll buy no monk that's a mirror
kenneth
oh no that's not right
mr baker we need to talk now's not a
great time kenneth i don't need anything
sir this time i need something from you
you've poisoned mr jordans and miss
maroney's minds
you've got to tell them to go back to
the way it was
to let me help everyone again including
you
kenneth yes you do
because you're scared and frustrated of
course i am because i'm going on tv
tomorrow and i don't know what i'm doing
yes embrace your anger what
yeah of all the weirdos i've met around
here you're the worst
with your creepy don knott's face that
ridiculous hitler youth haircut
excellent what about my chin what about
you chin kenneth i've seen bigger chins
on a premature baby mr baker
you've just made me feel terrible and
said the word about
correctly congratulations you're an
actor about about
oh my god thank you
kenneth oh there you are later
boy i am still not comfortable calling
you by your first name but then again
you've never been comfortable calling me
by my full christian name
kenneth oh no kenneth is short for
andrama ken of animal sorting
i have some real problems with this law
and order sbu script we can't say
dickwolf on tv the italians have a
saying lemon
keep your friends close and your enemies
closer and although they've never won a
war
or mass-produced a decent car in this
area they are correct
in five years we'll all either be
working for him
he'll be dead by his hand
you